when does this chair need to be back in
the [ __ ] attic
when does it need to be back on the
[ __ ] streets is that ikea
no yeah i've been bitten by 30 fire ants
living in the back of foam they've got
cats so i will say the lineup
but bobby lee is very funny and bobby
lee is the
is a fan favorite of all the comedians
and
very tough to get close to bobby lee
though we are
friends but he does this plexiglas is an
analogy what you put up
wait wait wait wait wait wait let me yes
number one okay
how she gets no i agree i fully agree
okay
i just want to say defend myself real
quick okay
that's me backing up mm-hmm right um
that
you know whenever you text i respond
that's just
yeah that's true okay and that's am i
everyone's
gonna say that's not true but there's a
couple times when you didn't and then
you go i don't text or call people back
i go
hmm that's a great policy
and then well do you have more scope
yeah yeah and um who's worse me or
oliver hudson
oh yeah he's gross really yeah i mean
yeah he's bad yeah he's pretty bad
in fact he texted me today i'll show you
what he texted me
and i did not respond because i know
that he wouldn't respond to my text
but his is uh oliver hudson today
at 2 44. i need you on daddy issues
oh that's his oh his show yeah his show
his other show yes oh
he has a show called daddy issues yes
with joe buck oh i thought he had
literal daddy i'm not [ __ ] kidding
you oh that's why the show is called
that
i did it you did daddy issues
he jumped the line in front of you did
he do is it through zoom or did you
everybody anyone wants to do a podcast i
go i gotta do bobby lee first
because it's only fair yeah yeah yeah
you gotta go through the system
i wanna get back to why you think it's
tough to get close
well there's a certain guard up
to not be now the covert thing is like a
[ __ ]
gift for him because now he can't go to
dinner because he can't leave the house
so i've asked him to go dinner and then
i gave up because i'll go i got adam
eager and i got
you know theo or tim dylan i go you want
to cruise and then i just stop because
the answer will be no if there's an
answer and
or he goes i don't do that i don't do
that what
eat go to dinner out yeah but i will see
you at the store
so if there's a reason this or the store
stop stop there i'll have i'll i'll say
one okay okay
you're not wrong i think he likes to
exist in people's lives in bursts
so he wants to i'll take anything i get
he'll he'll he'll give you himself in
bursts of an hour
every two weeks and but he has this fear
that any longer than an hour
you're going to stop liking him i get it
i get that a little bit
am i right or wrong oh um heavy man
okay no here's the all right you know
who
there's this black uh or a black guy i
know
oh my god why did you have an aneurysm
right now
you know because i just don't want to
get cancelled i i'm just trying to
figure out how
to say it yeah there's i said two things
and it's [ __ ] over i know what oh
yeah yeah and david spade laughed
i don't want to be the guy i'm not lying
go ahead you hate him so i know a guy
named aj jamal
yeah all right he used to be on he had
he did one season
on in living color okay wait hang on is
the fact that he was black
important or relevant to the story oh
god helping with the canceling
yeah no okay your camera
maybe you want us to picture it you know
that yeah yeah you know
aj jamal okay okay so this
has to do with mitzi so um when i first
moved to los angeles i was a doorman
and so i was a doorman at the la jolla
comedy store
and paulie goes dude you should
door up here brah so i go
you have no money but okay so i saved up
like a couple hundred bucks
i took my truck up there and i moved up
there you know i had a [ __ ]
pillowcase full of clothing no money
i show up and then i'm now working the
door you have an act
i i i know i have like five minutes okay
yeah i like five minutes
all doormen have an act yeah okay and so
i see mitzi walk in one day she goes oh
you're that chinese guy
from la hoya i go yeah and i sit in
cancer
yeah and then um after the brief
conversation she just walks away and aj
jamal pulls me inside and goes
you'll you'll i don't do an impression
yeah
so that's my bad it's true
it might be am i being dumb yeah so he
goes hey man
don't have a conversation with her
longer than five minutes
i go why because she's gonna reveal
things about yourself that you're not
gonna like
and also you might be able to you might
say something that's gonna forever
damage the relationship right so i only
did five minute pockets
with mitzi right and i think i use that
for some reason that approach to just
people in general
because i um because i have defense
mechanisms
but you know you don't know this
but right i probably have had more
dinners with you
than most people yeah and i know you're
we've had only dinner three to four
times right but
that's way more than anyone else you're
right you don't break bread with anybody
i don't break
bread and also how much how how how
highly do i talk about him yeah you are
a nice fish but i see at the store and
you're out there
uh in the hallway so we get to shoot the
[ __ ] there yeah
but i also want listen the pandemic like
that last one
listen the last one you called me about
is that
you had theo coming over for dinner for
the fight for the fights or something
right oh yeah
and um you know we you know this is
understandable but if it wasn't because
i'm a huge ufc
fan and if it wasn't before the pandemic
you know i mean i would have 100
because i could i the joy of hanging out
with you
and theo right right and watching the
fights would have been [ __ ] amazing
it's fun yeah and so when in 2021
if we're both alive and they find a
vaccine
right that i would you know what i'll
harass you
well it's funny because i we don't go to
the store anymore so it's fun to go
[ __ ] at dinner
so yeah we have a drink or two doesn't
drink
yeah just sit there and [ __ ] watch
the fight make fun of it make fun of
anything and he's
[ __ ] funny he's like i knew this kid
that had a really big ribs
i've heard that one [ __ ] all night and
yeah he's funny yeah he makes me [ __ ]
crackers he's such a funny
guy and then tim dillon's like you know
what you should be in jail and i'm like
um know
he has a lot to say which is hilarious
yeah yeah i don't even know him that
well i just started to and now
yeah when i was in palm springs i went
over to his place he's got a
cool place down there and just shot the
[ __ ] just for fun you know just fun to
[ __ ] why not because everyone i like
is smart funny comics so that's who i
gravitate to so those people are fun to
[ __ ] with
and they're usually along my lines i see
the scars sometimes i see uh
[Music]
well whoever i've already said but you
know i know a lot of people yeah
just from recently or they were on my
show the show was cancelled by the way
you know that
i didn't notice it's nice you didn't say
something but it is no no
but it isn't just comedy i thought
because comedy center was done